so what I would like to do in this video
is graph the inequality negative 14x
minus 7y is less than four like always I
encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can graph it on your own
before we work through it together so
the way that I like to do this is I like
to isolate a Y on one side of this
inequality and I'll do it on two on the
left hand side so the first thing I want
to do is let's get rid of this negative
14x here on the left so the best way to
do that is to add 14x but if I need to
do if I do that to the left hand side I
also want to do that on the right hand
side as well so I'm adding 14 X to both
sides and that leaves me with these two
cancel out on the left hand side I have
negative 7y and that's going to be less
than i have 14x plus 4 or 4 plus 14 X 14
X plus 4 and now I want to divide both
sides by negative 7 in order to isolate
this Y but we have to be very very very
careful when you multiply or divide both
sides of an inequality by a negative
number you need to swap this you need to
swap the inequality sign instead of it
being less than it would have to become
greater than so if you divide both sides
by negative 7 you are going to be left
with Y is greater than let me do that in
a different color just to highlight that
I'm swapping this around Y is gonna be
greater than 14 divided by negative 7 is
negative 2x and then 4 divided by
negative 7 well that's negative 4
sevenths and now I'm ready to graph this
and the way that I would graph this I
would graph y is equal to negative 2x
minus 4/7 but since we're not greater
than or equal to it I would put a dotted
line there and just shade everything
above that but let me just do what I'm
talking about so let me draw some axes
here
so there's gonna be an approximation
obviously this is a hand-drawn graph
that we're dealing with it's like that
that's my x-axis and let's see our
y-intercept is negative 4/7 which is a
little bit more than 1/2 so let's say
that this right over here is let's say
this right over here is 1 or negative 1
I should say actually I think I would
have to put my axis a little bit higher
so let's do it like this so that is X
let's make this negative 1 and then
that's about negative 2 and so this
would be 1 and then this is going to be
right about this is about 1 and then we
have 2 right over there so we look at
our y-intercept when X is so let's first
just think about what would we have 14
but Y is equal to negative 2x minus 4/7
well our y-intercept right over here
would be negative 4/7 which is a little
bit more than 1/2 so it'll be roughly
right around there and then we have a
slope of negative 2 we have a slope of
negative 2 so if you increase by 1 you
are going to decrease by - so you're
gonna decrease you can not gonna just go
there you're gonna go right around there
so you're gonna go right around there
and I'm gonna get my ruler tool out so I
can actually draw that so I'll connect
these two dots with my ruler tool now
remember I'm not just trying to graph y
equals and in fact this isn't greater
than or equal it's just strictly greater
than so let me draw a dotted line there
to show that I'm actually not going to
include the graph of y equals negative
2x minus 4/7 so let me do that dotted
line dotted line right over there so
that I'm not it's not going to be equal
to that it's all the Y's for any X that
are greater than that my spacing is
getting a little sloppy
so that does the job there you go so
that that would be the line y is equal
to negative 2x minus 4/7 but I dotted
lined it because this isn't greater than
or equal to if there was greater than or
equal to I would fill it in but it's
greater than to show that we don't
include the line but we want all of the
region all of the area above the line so
let me shade that in so that's gonna be
all of this actually I can shade it in
with a nice big juicy shading the right
tool out all right here we go so it
would be all of this area right over
here would be what I would actually
shade in so once again I don't include
the line I include everything above the
line and I am done